I want to go back a little bit on why
did we create constraint layout so if
you look at constantly at one we wanted
to have something that was a very
flexible layout manager something that
would allow you to to specify the way
your UI should be laid out and behave in
as much of a declarative way as possible
and in order to do that we created a
really rich model of constraints so you
could position your widget relatively to
one another you could Center them in
between each other with bias you have
circular positioning dimension
constraint and ratio and change which is
pretty interesting way of positioning a
group of widgets together so all of that
comes with you know a lot of power in to
help you create those layouts we also
add this idea of having helper objects
and the helper object object that are
not resulting automatically in a visual
difference by themselves but they will
allow you to set up your UI in an easier
way the typical example is guideline
where you know you can create those
guideline that your designers are so
fond of and just align the widget to
that which is nice because often before
that you you would have to translate you
know what they meant by guidelines in
your in your layout well here you can
simply create the guideline as in the
mug and align things to it in a similar
way we introduced the barrier helper in
the construct one one that you know
gives you some interesting behavior
where you could decide of a set of
widgets where to position yourself the
other important aspect on construct
layout and you'll see that's going to
come in at very handy for for the rest
of this talk it's this notion of trying
to keep the view hierarchy flat so there
is some performance reason for that but
more interestingly it's really this idea
of decoupling the layout information the
layout rules to the view with the view
hierarchy itself
and the nice thing with this is that we
have an object called constraint set
that can encapsulate all those rules and
you can create multiple instances of
this object swap them in or out
you're constantly out so that gives you
a lot of flexibility not only when you
to layout and create your UI but also at
runtime when you want to change all your
wife
and finally it's an unbundled library we
all sort of from the get-go I created
this layout to be supported in the
design tools so we have a pretty nice UI
builder and and that brings us to
construct layer - why did we create
cross track here - well the the key
element here is ready to try to create a
layout that is even more flexible we
wanted to give you back even more power
and we did that in a few ways one we
added the concept of virtual layouts
which are helpers that will do
essentially a lot of the Grand row for
you so you don't have to manually set
the constraint one by one you could
apply a set of constraints we had this
kind of the actual layout we have
helpers and decorators and also we
exposed a lot more of the internals of
constantly add for you and that that
means that you can do at runtime a lot
more stuff in constantly at - we also
did a lot of work in atomization and of
course a big highlight of construct
layer 2 is motion layout it's really you
know the more flexible way you can think
of for UI is introducing motion and
animation we still continue to to
strongly support design tooling and you
know specifically we are in the process
of building a motion editor in order to
do and we'll talk a little bit about
that and in order to use it it's very
easy just add this dependency to your
Gradle file and if you're using Android
X you know similar things just different
naming notice we just released 2.0 beta
one
so check it out we are pretty happy
where we are standing in terms of API
and yeah we are really looking forward
to you know what kind of feedback you
can give us so to to kind of you know
present things a little here is the
overall architecture of constantly add
we are starting with this very generic
solver that can do a lot of computation
for us and express your layout in very
complex way but we don't expose that
directly what we expose this this
constraint model the nice thing with
this is that we can in between add an
optimizer that take care of a lot of
situations that are very you know an
ambiguous and don't need it in a solver
so that gives us a lot more speed in
constantly up to the on top of that we
are the helpers object and the virtual
layout that are kind of using this
construct model for you and above all of
this we have motion layout that takes
advantage of this entire foundation let
me cover a little bit the constraint
helpers so as I explained we did have
helpers in constantly at one in
constantly to we expose that class so
not only we can continue to create
helpers for you but you can actually
create your own address so the thing
that's important to note is with the
helpers is that they are not of your
group we are not adding a layer and an
extra layer of hierarchy there all we do
is we essentially tag the widgets with
that helper and the nice property is
that you can actually have multiple
helpers tagging multiple the same
widgets so one would add can actually
have its behavior change by multiple
helpers but the general idea is that if
you have a repeatable behavior you can
encapsulate it and just use it in a
declarative way in XML and you don't
have to do code after that a basic
example is a circular reveal nothing too
fancy here I'm just having a reveal
pointing to the different widget that
appears what's interesting is the actual
code it is we are not reinventing the
wheel it's just of your animation
materials
but we encapsulated into a helper and
therefore we can simply use it in your
XML file without having to do any
programming virtual layout is another
type of helpers and as I mentioned
before the idea is to still keep the
hierarchy flat it will position the
widget for you what's what's nice is
because we still are the same level of
the hierarchy you can reference widget
that are inside the virtual layout and
vice versa so you can also do a lot more
runtime changes on the fly right and let
me cover flow which is a virtual layout
we introduced recently flows report
multiple mode on helping you layout
objects the first mode is essentially
creating a chain for you there is no
reason tile or vertical and we can also
sleep out different wrap modes when the
first one is essentially still using
chains as we go along the other one is
doing a little more interesting behavior
so this is what it looks like it looks
like a normal widget we reference you
know older widget it to a helper as a
normal widget you can see set it
dimensions wrap content and etc and you
can constrain it like any other wedge I
think on Sonic layout so it's a very
familiar pattern you can even set up the
background which is kind of handy in
some situations and the devil builders I
said is to create a chain so we do
support all the type of chain spread
chain spread inside pact and that allows
you very quickly to set up those those
behavior what's new is the wrap behavior
editor akin to flexbox layout where you
know if you don't have the space before
you can offer another special you come
to anything else but now we will create
automatically an extra chain for you by
default we are using this the same type
of chain for all the different chains
but you can actually specify the front
chain between your first chain and the
rest of the chains you can also set up a
max element
before you decide to rap which is kind
of funny to create a table like behavior
or is it well the problem here is if the
elements out don't have the same size
you're not going to have a grid right
because you'll still up a chain and
that's where the last mode comes in
where we will align the element in rows
and column for you so the here's an
actual example on how to use it I'm
going to take up sorry a UI that
definitely looks like something that
could use flow a basic calculator and I
want to create the body of that
calculator all like that and the first
step is I'm going to set up the flow
make it wrap content Center it in the
parent reference the elements add a
couple of attributes to define how it's
going to behave and we end up with this
result
no very easy you don't have to create
all the chains by hand all the
constraint by hand you just reference
them what's nice is it's a normal widget
in the as it's a normal child of
constant layout so you can here
constraint another widget to that flow
element very in exactly the same way as
you would do normally
what's even better is that you can do
the same for the inside element so here
I have this other textview that I
actually constraint on those internal
buttons the also step that we took to
bring more flexibility in caution here
too is adding more api's for youth
videos we we have the constraint set api
which is this you know way of basically
getting you know the state of the layout
and you can change it and reapply to
constantly out we have a new api that
instead of you having to manually go and
modify layout params you know we provide
this free odds API that lets you change
them and we'll do the right things in an
efficient way and there is more there is
more stuff I'm not going to cover too
much but we have we have the resize on
the fly resize and being state managed
nodes we even added margins on barrier
there's a lot more stuff that really
here what I'd like to talk about and I'm
going to run over to John is motion
layout so for those who don't know
motion layout is a subclass of
constraint layout it has a separate XML
file for the constraints and the motion
elements called a motion scene file and
it allows you to directly animate
between two complete constraint sets so
the way it basically works is you have
constraint sets we call them States
internally and you can transition
between them you can also manipulate the
transition with a keyframe and those can
be in a lot of different areas and Alex
I'll show more one of the unique things
about the system is it has a few
different coordinate systems very
important because in in this sort of
situation you're moving between two
undefined states the phone could be
different it could be in landscape
whatever you need to have a coordinate
system that can handle that so one of
them is parent relative another one of
them is Delta relative which is actually
the default it allows you to move in x
and y separately the other one is path
relative so if you're deforming around
the path that allows you to do that the
other thing that we build is a lot of
clever on swipe and unclick behaviors
and actually in the beta there's some
new stuff in there that's quite exciting
so how is it basically laid out in your
layout file you'll have your views your
helpers your virtual layouts and it'll
point to the transition the constraint
set
essentially the motion scene file so
let's do an example okay so the basic
stuff on how you can use motion layout
is you need two states right so here I'm
having my little CERN and moving from
one state to the other it's also not
super realistic typically us and would
go a little higher so that's one of the
nice thing with constraint we've also
constantly are true in motion at is that
you can tweak how you get from the state
to the end it's not just enough to do to
define those two states because often
you want to do a transition that is not
linear so here I just want to add for
example an arc motion right and I can
simply do that by adding a key position
like a keyframe that's going to control
the position at the middle of the
animation in a similar way often you
want to do more than just positioning
you want to change other type of
attributes like here the color and we
can do that as well so that's where
motion it goes much beyond the pure
layout capabilities we can change and
interpolate to you know across a lot of
attributes oh sorry
we have a couple of extra features that
are interesting with sorry cycles that
just by separated with the animation as
well you notice that here the animation
is still playing even though we are in
the middle of the transition and to
cover all of that in more details
so we'll just go through the main tags
there's key position and essentially it
just deforms your path using the
coordinate system and in this case I pin
it to the right to the complete Delta X
equal one next one is key attributes you
can manipulate rotation and any of the
post layout transforms you can do custom
attributes with which we'll reflectively
call all the different api's so what are
they ignore complex
things we add is key cycles they allow
interactive animations in the in space
so as that the object progresses it will
animate and it will just simply provide
II Delta in the position now you can
apply key cycles to any attributes so it
can be rotation and you'll see a whole
bunch of them as as we go along so in
this case if the as the animation
progresses its animating across the
entire scene which is very different
from key time cycles where the animation
is independent of the position it's sort
of setting the frequency of the
animation and and of course you can
deform these things with lots of clever
shapes and paths and produce lots of
interesting effects so one of the other
things that we don't really talk about
much and when I mention is programmatic
control here we can essentially as we
animate we can make a programmatic
change in direction in real time so what
will happen is you're in an undefined
State because you're halfway between two
states this start in the end if you
issue a command transition to a new
state it will sort of recreate a
transition between where you were at
that point in time and the new position
that you were requested so it's it can
be relatively interactive with your
application we also have commands that
allow you to get the constraint set
involve and then it's a constraint set
it's an API we've had since 1.0 you can
go and change values and apply it back
into the system and rebuild the scene
you can also actually point to a
completely new seen another XML layout
file a motion scene file and it will
just naturally adapt to that new one
so there are actually a lot of little
api's in the in it to allow you to
control things dynamically based on your
application so one of the other things I
wanted to show is that we can integrate
will help us so this is flow layout as
we just talked about and in fact all of
these views are are in it but within the
constraint set you can set the IDs of
all the views that are inside the flow
so that you can change on the fly and it
will animate between the two layouts
dynamically so you can pop out views
things like that so one of the other
things that is pretty important is touch
handling it tracks your velocity of your
finger and matches the velocity of the
object you tagged to it if you leave out
an object to anchor to it it will just
be a percentage of the screen size and
you can you can change a lot of
parameters on it about the velocity how
you want it to terminate things like
that there they're actually quite a few
parameters on system there so let's talk
a little bit about the motion as and why
we needed to do marble
if you look at what you see here in the
motion editor you're gonna drive Android
studio crazy it's very it beats up on
Android studio like you wouldn't believe
and unlike let's say a mouse interaction
where you're dragging you drag and you
stop someone could leave this running
and go to lunch and they're stuck the
system has to be able to handle 60
frames per second
continuous are over and over again and
this is something I just built a to show
off what it looks like
what you can do and here is it an in in
crazy because I thought I'm sorry it
didn't because it's cute
so now let's let's actually go through a
little bit about the editor we're not
gonna release it yet we're still working
on it but it's my main job from now till
it releases so this is this is a copy of
what's right now in master and we're
running it so what you'll do is you'll
take a constraint layout and you'll just
right click and say converts emotionally
out and and then this is what you'll see
you can go ahead and select a set of
constraints create a collection of
constraint sets for the starting and the
ending and then make some changes on the
ending and in this case I just shortened
one of the values and it animates that
that's pretty much it you can go ahead
and change all the attributes so it's
coming it we were working on it and I'm
hoping as within the next few months
you'll sort of see versions in alpha
don't know when okay so Nicholas yeah so
let's talk a little bit on how you can
actually use motion the arts in your
applications first of all all those
examples are on the github repository we
set up so check it out it should be very
straightforward all the examples all the
xml's all the code so how do we
integrate motion layout with your with
your application
the basic thing to think of is that you
don't have to reinvent to start from the
ground zero right you can you can start
to use motion they are today and
integrate it in your current UI so
here's a couple of examples if you have
a coordinate a layout and you have a
collapsible toolbar
a the em if you want to have this kind
of animated toolbar it's right on it's
pretty difficult you have to do a lot of
code or what you can do is simply take a
motion layout and use it as the
collapsible toolbar and you you can see
on the on the github repository it's
really straightforward you you have just
one little bit of code to pass over the
progress of the coordinate or layout and
motion the art is going to do the rest
so that's really democratize this type
of motion in a very similar way in very
similar pattern you can you know go
crazy we withdraw our layouts or you can
you know make a viewpager a little more
fancy but on my design skills and you
can use motion you know a lot of
different ways so what are the ways I
wanted to highlight today is building a
custom components well this actually
came from someone asking about can I do
this and it's like yeah of course you
can
so starting really simple let's say you
just wanted to have a button that had a
little flash to it you can build it a
button out of motion layout do the
animation and decide how it reacts when
you click on it and when you don't click
on it and all these examples are in just
pure XML there's no code behind this one
in terms of from a user perspective but
you can get fancy in a bunch of
different ways these are three different
examples I just built up a few of them
the the top one is interesting in that
what's happening there is there are five
different states it can be in I have
different constraint sets and and we
have ways to make it very easy to to
build a derived constraint set from
another constraint set so you can derive
and arrive and derive and and what
you're seeing here is that the swipe
handling is going across all of the
constraint sets because there's a swipe
that moves you from one to the next to
the next and it all happens smoothly the
second one is simply a swipe left right
I added a key cycle to make it look like
the object is rotating and the third one
is adding some cycles to give you that
bouncy effect I assume you've seen
something like that if you have liked
anything in the past so the the I show
you a little bit of multi-state I wanted
to kind of highlight that notice there
there four states here five states here
the one in the center and I'm swiping
across them I'm clicking on buttons
which transfer them so you can actually
transfer between all the states and it
all happens seamlessly and you'll see
that to the extreme in a later example
so it allows you to have many different
states and do many things very flexibly
with them it's way too much to actually
go into all the little details that that
are involved here all the different
possibilities but we'll we'll go into
yeah so another way that you can use
motion layout is by driving other
components like what we've seen so far
is essentially taking motion layout and
animating stuff inside it but kind of
like terminal widgets right but you can
also think about motion layout as
something to do what coordinator
laureate would do and here in that
example motion node is actually handling
the scoring of the image but driving
this custom view that's going to you
know get this this line being going into
a circle like that so you can easily
drive your own custom views that would
have a specific type of animation and
having motion that acts as you know
scene coordinator in a similar way you
can take a motion layout and put it into
another motion layer so which with you
know we've seen this at the same example
essentially we've coordinate a layout
but that example actually does the same
behavior purely in motion layout and how
it works is very basic you have one
motion layout the outer one level
one we've started and States simply
containing a motion layout for the
collapsible bar and we set the progress
of that circle motion layout from the
first one and the key here is not so
much like we are about to replicate
coordinates well they are the key is
that we don't know what you know your
designers are going to come up as crazy
ideas for you I you know mixture order
year after that so
by essentially having with the power of
expressing this type of things you know
we ensure a lot more we should be much
more future proof the other thing is all
of that has absolutely zero code it's
pure declarative in XML which is very
handy when you can do that because it's
a lot easier to change there's a lot
less side effect to think about than
code but sometimes code and you know
programming can be quite handy when you
want to do some runtime behaviors so
let's see what we can integrate
recyclerview with motion layout or take
advantage of motion layout in
recyclerview so I've got my screen with
a basic recycler view and I'd like to be
able to have this kind of motion I take
my element and just make it fullscreen
right so we can t find that absolutely
trivially in motion layout and I define
the two states very easy of course the
issue is that the position of that
element that I'm animating changes all
the time I don't know where it is on
screen so you can basically in your in
the transition listener you can
basically hook that get the crown
constraint set clear the item up sorry
clear the item calculate the new bounds
pass it back and reapply it and that's
enough for you to then apply that and we
can use motion layout to animate that
element there's a little more magic
around here because remember it's
computer graphics we do tricks all the
time what I'm doing here is I'm actually
making the element of the recyclerview
being
invisible recreating an element boutique
putting it in the motion layout and
animating is that one that would
ordinarily be not that simple to do
other than the fact that recyclerview
does exactly that an adapter in
recyclerview does just that it it knows
how to create a new view how to populate
it and it simply in that example what we
are using now the thing that is really
cool here is not so much that we can do
that because we could have done it in a
different way notice so that I'm driving
that by my finger so it's not it's not a
fire-and-forget I'm actually dragging
that element but because now that
animation is done in motion layout in
emotions in XML file I can go and tweak
it absolutely trivially so instead of
this basic animation let's say that I
would like to delay a little bit the
position of that element it's I'm just
adding this element in the motions in
file and it will just do that so again
the advantage of being declarative like
that it gives you a lot more power a lot
more flexible way of tweaking your
design and you don't have to look at
your code it's completely iterated we
can go even crazier let's say that I'm
adding rotation here because why not and
then you can you can get this kind of
sorry this kind of effect where you know
it's really I'm not a good designer
right bear with me but you get the idea
you have all the features and
capabilities of motion layouts at your
fingertips and just go with it so that
example was interesting but there is a
patent as very common in in UI with with
this kind of infinite list and for that
pattern we we have an interesting
solution so when we have a carousel like
that you actually know exactly how many
elements you have on screen typically
you have one and you may have one one
element that comes in when any man that
comes out but essentially the number of
demands that
you're playing with is limited and more
importantly you know about them
recyclerview does that of course but
does a lot more recyclerview is going to
compute how many elements you need it's
going to lay them out etc etc so I'm not
saying don't use recyclerview but if you
have this type of pattern we could do
something a little more interesting
purely in motion layouts so let's do
that if that's my you know starting
position I may want to go you know swipe
on on the right or a swipe on the left
and essentially I can translate that as
different state in motion layouts I have
a start state next state previous States
motion yet supports multi states and we
can take advantage of that so what do we
do with this the trick here is this
little bit of code and specifically that
stuff when I reach the state next what
I'm doing I reset the progress to zero
to the start state and I'm updating my
images so we were visually this is what
it looks like we get that we go to the
next state and then moving back the
progress to zero and updating my images
so that's what happens internally what
you see as the user is a little more
seamless you have this you swipe and
essentially it looks like the element
gets added back to the to the new cue so
it's a little bit of magic but it works
really well and here's a quick example I
have something that looks very much like
up sorry like a recycler view you notice
a couple of decorators playing in the
background and you notice that I can
just scroll like that but you got motion
layout so you can go crazy on the
transformation you can go and add many
more States to it
here is a quick other example where I'm
sorry where it does the same same type
of idea but just in a different pattern
so really did what I'm trying to say
here is that you can go much beyond
what we as the android framework defined
for you
motion layout is really a toolbox for
you to experiment and you know come up
with something new so to wrap up this
presentation first there is a lot of
documentation we put out there there is
the the DAC documentation on developer
Android comm there's various medium
articles and we are going to continue to
publish those articles as well I highly
recommend you to check out the github
repository because tons of examples and
you know I don't know about you but as a
programmer I love seeing examples and
kind of riff off of that and essentially
the the motion layouts as part of
constantly out - we are pretty happy
with where it stands in terms of the
features which is why we reach beta 1 so
I encourage you to check out beta 1 play
with it and you know gives us feedback
really we we really cannot wait to see
what you're going to come up with that
and again important feedback we have a
bug tracker we look at all bugs we try
to go through them and the final stuff I
wanted to say about the motion editor as
John said we post it temporarily to walk
on Android studio model to ensure that
actually we have the performances to do
a good motion editor but we are very
much intent on shipping that editor in
the next few months if you guys build
any cool examples share them on Twitter
so we all could see them and enjoy them
I look on Twitter every day looking for
them so I hope to see some pretty
examples from you guys thanks
[Applause]
[Music]